welcome back to facebook HQ for ask the
Chancellor's that is actual Mark
Zuckerberg they're doing a conference so
this is our studio
/ canteen
best thing about Facebook free food all
day and sweets but I've given up for
Lent I'm Shauna when i'm 23 and what I'd
like to know is how the future
government are going to make sure they
invested all young people salima dink
and a car from solutions publishing and
manse they're looking forward to finding
out a bit more about hey Chester 2 i'm
from sports nutrition brand bulk powders
but i want to find out why there's more
v80 on healthy nutrition than bad good
to see that there is our pop-up gallery
so that's why we lose the balls has just
entered the building Mr Osborne is in
there maybe we'll get that head to head
after all
star 40 rounds okay and do to make this
better and fairer filled with chemicals
to keep it keep it so that you wouldn't
really event is over that it was is
still taking questions here from the
audience for me I think Ed Balls won
today's debate purely on having the
nicest suits George Osborne stood up for
me because of me being the construction
industry in his years and
apprenticeships I've could burn about a
ball but don't think he's giving the
rural economy enough support and that is
a wrap and it's not a bad view for
dinner